[संगीत]
[प्रशंसा]
खुदा
[संगीत]
[प्रशंसा]
हेलो एवरीवन गुड इवनिंग दोस्तों एक बार
सभी लोग कंफर्म कर दीजिए की मेरी कर सको
इसे सुने दे दिया
हमारी मुलाकात हुई है और कितना मैंने
उम्मीद किया था
क्योंकि आज का जो हमारा टॉपिक है वह है
सोशल मीडिया ओपन सोशल इंटेलिजेंस स्टार्ट
करने जा रहा हूं और ज्यादा मुझे पता है
सबसे डिमांड हो सबसे सब का फेवरेट टॉपिक
है ये जिसमें हम पढ़ने वाले हैं ट्विटर पर
टेलिजेंस के बड़े में फेसबुक ओपन सोशल
टेलिजेंस के बड़े में इंस्टाग्राम ओपन
सोशल इंटेलिजेंस के बड़े में लिंकडइन ओपन
सोशल इंटेलिजेंस के बड़े में थोड़ा बहुत
और कुछ एक्स्ट्रा काफी अच्छे से काफी
डिटेल बढ़ेंगे हम डिशनर्ययों बेस रखेंगे
बट क्या है की साड़ी चीज डेयर में रहते
हुए हम कम करेंगे
तो
बाकी मुझे तो लगता था की सबका फेवरेट
टॉपिक है तो काफी लोग आएंगे और काफी लोग
इसको अटेंड करेंगे
और जब बात आई है हैकिंग की एथिकल हैकिंग
की या फैंटास्टिक की बात आई है उसमें भी
सबसे पहले बात आई है ओपन सोर्स इंटेलिजेंस
एक्टिविटीज की तो
हर एक एथिकल हैकर्स क्या करता है की जब
किसी भी ऑर्गेनाइजेशन के बड़े में
इनफॉरमेशन कलेक्ट करने की बात आई है या
किसी भी टारगेट के बड़े में किसी भी मोस्ट
फेमस परसों के बड़े में इनफॉरमेशन गैलिंग
की बात आई है विद डी हेल्प ऑफ ओपन सोशल
इंटेलिजेंस तो वह
ट्विटर ओसियन का उसे करके काफी कुछ
इनफॉरमेशन गदर कर सकता है अपने टारगेट के
बड़े में
अब लोग क्या करते हैं की ट्विटर का
यूजुअली इसलिए करते हैं वह अपने विचार
अपने इंटरेस्ट अपने इमोशंस साड़ी चीज क्या
करते हैं
शेर करने की कोशिश करते हैं
जो किसी भी हैकर को
हेल्प करती है
जस्ट मिनट गाइड्स
चलो बात करते हैं फिर कंटिन्यू करते हैं
तो अब टारगेट 2 लोग हैं वह मतलब की जो
हैकर्स की बात कर रहा था मैं एग्रीकल्चर
की बात कर रहा हूं वो काफी कुछ इनफॉरमेशन
गदर करते हैं किसकी हेल्प से ट्विटर की
हेल्प से और लोग क्या करते हैं ट्विटर का
उसे करते हैं अपने विचारों को शेर करने के
लिए अपने टेस्ट को शेर करने के लिए तो आप
ट्विटर क्या है ट्विटर एक बहुत ही अच्छा
प्लेटफॉर्म है और खासकर की हैकर्स के लिए
एथिकल हैकर्स के लिए वह साड़ी एक्टिविटी
परफॉर्म करने के लिए किसी भी टारगेट कंपनी
के बड़े में किसी भी टारगेट के बड़े में
किसी भी इंडिविजुअल इंडिविजुअल के बड़े
में खासकर की उसकी वेबसाइट एक्टिविटीज को
मॉनिटर करने के लिए उसकी आउटसाइड
इनफॉरमेशन को
आउटसाइड की क्या करने के लिए एक्सप्लोइट
करने के लिए किसी भी ऑर्गेनाइजेशन को तो
ट्विटर उसके लिए काफी गुड ब्रेकफास्ट
अगर कोई भी आपके पर एग्जांपल कोई भी आपको
कोई भी टारगेट है उसे टारगेट में चाहे वो
आपकी कोई भी कंपनी हो शक्ति है टारगेट में
कोई भी ऑर्गेनाइजेशन हो शक्ति है टारगेट
में कोई भी एक काफी पॉपुलर परसंस हो सकते
हैं लोग हो सकते हैं अगर उनका ट्विटर
अकाउंट है और वो काफी एक्टिवली उसे कर रहे
हैं उसको काफी टाइम से उसे करले हैं तो
डेफिनेटली आपको वहां पर काफी कुछ
सिग्निफिकेंट अमाउंट ऑफ इनफॉरमेशन आपको
उनके बड़े में देखने को मिल शक्ति है
अब आप लोगों को दिमाग में एक ही सवाल होगा
की व्हाइट प्लेटफॉर्म इंटेलिजेंस
एक्टिविटीज देखो क्या है की
मी इसे मोस्टली यूज्ड बाय प्रोफेशनल पीपल
और पीपल इन ट्रैक
कमेंट्स लाइक और पोस्ट समझ में आया
इंग्लिश में
बता देता हूं
प्रोफेशनल लोगो के द्वारा ही उसे किया
जाता है उसमें जो लोग क्या करते हैं
किसके थ्रू ही कर सकते हैं पीपल एक दूसरे
क्योंकि देखो हर किसी के पास हर किसी के
कांटेक्ट नहीं है
बट क्या करता है वो एक दूसरे कांटेक्ट एक
दूसरे चाट एक दूसरे बातें इसके थ्रू करते
हैं या तो कमेंट्स के थ्रू करते हैं यार
कमेंट्स के थ्रू करते हैं
एक दूसरे को इनफॉरमेशन शेयरिंग करते हैं
अब बात करते हैं अब मैं आपको क्या बताने
वाला हूं देखो
मैं आपको जो जो भी कुछ बताने वाला हूं
देखो हम
[संगीत]
तो बात करते हैं देखो जो भी मैं आपको
बताने वाला हूं जो आज हम सीखने वाले हैं
बेसिकली ट्विटर के अंदर ट्विटर ओपन सोशल
के बड़े में की मैं आपको कुछ एडवांस ट्रिक
और कुछ ऐसे टैक्स बताऊंगा जो किसी कोई भी
एथिकल हैकर्स के द्वारा उसे की जाति है
इनफॉरमेशन को रिवील करने के लिए आपकी किसी
भी टारगेट के बड़े में तो अब बात करते हैं
ट्विटर ओपन 100 से इंटेलिजेंस मैथर्ड के
बड़े में देखो क्या है की ट्विटर का उसे
करके आप क्या कर सकते हो की दो त्रिकोण से
मेथड के दो दो मैथर्ड होते हैं जिनकी
हेल्प से क्या कर सकते हो आप ट्विटर के
थ्रू ओपन 100 से इंटेलिजेंस कर सकते हो
नॉन टेक्निकल मेथड होता है
नॉन टेक्निकल्स मेथड को हम ट्रेडिशनल
मैथर्ड भी बोल सकते हैं या
ट्रेडिशनल
मैथर्ड जो टेक्निकल मैथर्ड के हैं जनरली
क्या है एथिकल हैकर्स या हैकर्स के द्वारा
ही उसे किया जाता है अब जो ट्रेडिशनल
मैथर्ड है या नॉन टेक्निकल मैथर्ड हैं
उसमें क्या होता है देखो नॉन टेक्निकल
मेथड कौन सा होता है की कोई भी एक ऐसा
व्यक्ति जो ट्विटर को काफी टाइम से उसे कर
रहा है काफी टाइम से उसको एक्सपीरियंस से
चलने का ट्विटर का तो क्या कर सकता है वो
एक जनरल इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग कर सकता है
मतलब क्योंकि एक्चुअल में क्या होता है की
कोई भी है एवं एवं एथिकल फैंटास्टिक के
अलावा किसी को पता नहीं की वो क्या है
जस्ट ओनली अपने लाइक कमेंट पोस्ट के लिए
ही क्या करते हैं ट्विटर को उसे करते हैं
एक्शन चीजों को परफॉर्म करना नहीं आता
काफी उनको भले ही कितना एक्सपीरियंस हो
लेकिन कई बार क्या होता है की एक्सप्रेस
का उसे करके वो थोड़ा बहुत इनफॉरमेशन
क्रैक कर लेते हैं और जब बात आई है
क्योंकि एक ट्रेडिशनल मेथड है जब बात जाति
है एक हैकर्स की बात आई है इसमें कहती कल
हैकर्स की बात आई है तो वो क्या करता है
कोई ट्रेडिशनल मेथड का उसे करता है एक
हैकिंग मन सेट के साथ जब एक हैकिंग मन सेट
के साथ इस इनफॉरमेशन ट्रेडिशनल मेथड का
उसे किया जाता है तो वो यहां पर क्या करता
है वो कुछ स्किल का उसे करता है अपनी कुछ
मैनिपुलेशन टेक्निक्स कुछ ट्रिक और कुछ
नॉलेज उसके पास जो पहले से कुछ नॉलेज है
अपने फील्ड की उसका उसे करते हैं वो क्या
करता है वो आपको काफी इनफॉरमेशन कलेक्ट
करने की कोशिश करता है जो एक नॉर्मल
व्यक्ति उसे इनफॉरमेशन को कलेक्ट नहीं कर
सकता
तो अब बात करते हैं की टेक्निकल मेथड कौन
सा होता है देखो एक चीज है
काफी इंपॉर्टेंट आप लोगों को बता देता हूं
की विदाउट ट्रेडिशनल मेथड विदाउट नॉन
टेक्निकल मेथड आप क्या कर सकते हो आप
टेक्निकल मेथड उसे कर सकते हो बट बेनिफिट
नहीं रहेगा
किसी भी टारगेट के बड़े में किसी भी
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन के बड़े में
तो मैं आपको सबसे पहले स्टार्ट करूंगा
सबसे पहले मैं आपको सिखाऊंगा इनफॉरमेशन
उसको फिनिश करेंगे काफी कुछ एडवांस
टेक्निक सीखने के बाद तो अगेन आप लोगों के
लिए एक डिस्क्लेमर है यहां भी जितनी भी
चीज हम उसे करेंगे डी टेक्निकल मेथड से
करें या नॉन टेक्निकल मेथड से उसे करें या
ईमेल में जी ऑर्गेनाइजेशन को ऐसे एग्जांपल
पर एजुकेशन परपज के लिए मैं आप लोगों को
क्या कर रहा हूं की ऑर्गेनाइजेशन को अगर
मैं यहां पर टारगेट भी कर रहा हूं बट ओनली
पर एजुकेशन परपज है आप लोग उसको उसे नहीं
करोगे वो सब ना उसे करूंगा मेरे मेरे
अलावा कुछ भी कर सकते हो बट क्या करना
आपको मेरे वाले इनफॉरमेशन को फॉलो नहीं
करना है मेरे वाले टारगेट को फॉलो नहीं
करना है
अगर चाहे तो देखो आपने अगर कुछ भी करने की
कोशिश कारी वे आर नोट रिस्पांसिबल
डिप्रॉनिक्स कंपनी आपके लिए रिस्पांसिबल
नहीं होगी उसे आप खुद के लिए रिस्पांसिबल
होंगे क्योंकि आज जो भी कुछ हम सीखने वाले
हैं पूरा पूरा एजुकेशन परपज के लिए है कोई
भी उसको मिस उसे करने की कोशिश नहीं करेगा
कोई भी उसके साथ कुछ भी गलत
एक्टिविटी मन में रखते हुए उसको उसे ना
करें तो यह था आप लोगों के लिए एक
वार्निंग ये थ्रोट वार्निंग रहेगी की बाद
में बोलोगे कुछ ऐसे शब्द अगर मैंने पढ़ते
पढ़ते फॉलो में उसे कर लिए अगर बाद में
फिर बोलोगे सर आपने तो ऐसा बोला था नोट यह
पहले ही आप लोगों के लिए वार्निंग है
क्योंकि सीरियस टॉवल्स के लिए आप
रिस्पांसिबल हो गए क्योंकि यह साड़ी चीज
देखने को मिल शक्ति हो सकता है की मैंने
भी अभी तक नहीं अच्छी हूं क्योंकि आज मैं
जो टारगेट उसे करने वाला मैंने अभी तक
इसके ऊपर कुछ भी परफॉर्मेंस नहीं किया है
की मैं आपसे आज क्लास लेने से पहले मैं आप
लोगों के लिए कोई टारगेट उसे करके नहीं
लेकर आया
तो अब बात करते हैं जब भी आप अब बात करता
हूं मैं की आपको जितने भी अभी तक
इंटेलिजेंस आप लोगों ने उसे की है या आगे
उसे करने वाले हो उसके लिए एक सेफ्टी
स्टेप्स की बात कर रहा हूं मैं उसके लिए
आपको मैं बताने जा रहा हूं देखो क्या करना
है की आपको जब भी ओपन सोर्स इंटेलिजेंस
परफॉर्म करने की कोशिश करोगे चाहे वो सोशल
मीडिया हो या इमेज रिवर्स सर्च हो कुछ भी
हो तो बेसिकली आप जितना कोशिश कीजिए तो
आपको मोबाइल फोन या मोबाइल एप्लीकेशंस का
उसे नहीं करना चाहिए
सबसे पहले बात आपको क्या करना है मोबाइल
एप्लीकेशन का उसे नहीं करना है
आपको मोबाइल्स को दूर रखना है खास करके जब
आप कोई भी इस टाइप का कम करने की सोच रहे
हो इस टाइप की अगर आपके दिमाग में हैकिंग
एक्टिविटीज परफॉर्म करने के लिए भी अगर आप
लोग सोच रहे हो तो आपको क्या करना है की
आपको मोबाइल फोन को उसे नहीं करना है
क्योंकि ये आपकी आपको डाइजेस्ट कर सकता है
मतलब की आपको एक्सपोज कर सकता है आपका पता
ग जाएगा की आप कहां बैठकर ये चीज कर रहे
हो
उसके बाद क्या है की सबसे बटर चीज क्या है
की आप क्या कर सकते हो एक विजिबल
एनवायरनमेंट बना के रखिए अपने मशीन के
अंदर मतलब अपनी लैपटॉप्स अपने डेस्कटॉप
पीसी के अंदर और उसमें क्या-क्या मैचुअल
इमेंडमेंट क्रिएट करने के लिए आप लोगों को
पहले से पता अगर नहीं पता तो उसके लिए
आपने पीएम वेयर या बचपन बुक्स का उसे कर
सकते हैं इसमें आप उसे कर सकते हो
लाइनेक्स ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम लाइनेक्स
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम में जब आप फायरफॉक्स या
गूगल क्रोम कुछ भी उसे करो और उसके अंदर
भी अगर आप क्या करते हो उसका प्राइवेट तब
होता है उसको अगर उसे करोगे तो आपको काफी
कुछ हद तक क्या है अनुमति मिलेगी लेकिन
ज्यादा नहीं मिलेगी लेकिन इससे बटर रहेगा
डायरेक्टली आप इंगेज होने के बजे अगर आप
साथ में अगर यू वांट तू विकम बेस्ट ओपन
इन्वेस्टिगेटर अगर आप बेस्ट बन्ना चाहते
हो और आपने आपको थोड़ा बहुत हायड करके
रखना चाहते हो तो मी सजेशन की आप वीपीएन
उसे कर सकते हो उसके साथ में थोड़ा टाइम
लगेगा किसी भी इनफॉरमेशन को कलेक्ट करने
में वीपीएन करने से क्या है की आप
अनुमानाइज हो जाओगे आपके बड़े में खुद
आपको रिव्यू करने में थोड़ा सा टाइम लगेगा
किसी को भी तो आप ऐसा कर सकते हो दूसरी
चीज आप दिमाग में क्या रख सकते हो दूसरा
चीज क्या है की आपको हर चीज के लिए आपको
हर एक चीज के लिए क्या करने हैं नोट
मेकिंग करनी है मतलब की चाहे आप वन नोट का
उसे करें चाहे गूगल दोस्त इसका उसे करें
दी ओ सी एस जिसको बोलते हैं लॉकेट बोलते
हैं उसका उसे करें या हैंड का उसे करें
वॅटीवर तरीका आपके पास जो भी पैटर्न है आप
वहीं पर भी आपको क्या करना है नोट मेकिंग
करनी चाहिए जो भी इनफॉरमेशन आपको अपने
टारगेट के बड़े में मिल रही है वॅटीवर यू
नोटिस इनफॉरमेशन
आपके लिए आपके पास बहुत सारे हैकिंग
सिनेरियस होते हैं बहुत सारे तरीकेज होते
हैं टेक परफॉर्म करने के तो उसे इनफॉरमेशन
का आप उसे कर सकते हो जो भी आपने राइट डॉ
की है आप अपने टारगेट को अटैक करने के लिए
एवं आप एक्सपर्ट करने के लिए अपनी सिस्टम
को अपने डिवाइस को या उसके सॉरी आपने नहीं
उसके डिवाइस अटैक उसके सॉरी टारगेट के
डिवाइस को एक्सप्लोइट करने के लिए सिस्टम
को एक्सप्लोरर करने के लिए उसके नेटवर्क
करने के लिए आप उसे इनफॉरमेशन का उसे
करोगे अब बात करते हैं इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग
जब आप करते हो तो जितनी ज्यादा आपके पास
पर्टिकुलर टारगेट के बड़े में आपके पास
जितनी ज्यादा इनफॉरमेशन होगी उतनी ज्यादा
आपके पास मिल जाए
अब चाहे
सिक्योरिटी अवेयरनेस रिलेटेड हो चाहे वह
बोलना बेटी आपकी किसी भी टारगेट डिवाइस
है उसके चांसेस बाढ़ जाएंगे आपको फाइंड
आउट करने के ये अगर आप इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग
अगर अच्छे तरीके से परफॉर्म कर पाते हो तो
इसलिए आईटी इस वेरी इंपॉर्टेंट तू नोट
इसलिए मैं आपको एडवाइस कर रहा हूं सबसे
ज्यादा जरूरी है की जितनी भी चीज आपको
लगता है की वो रेलीवेंट है या आई रेलीवेंट
है आपको उसकी नोट मेकिंग करनी चाहिए
अगर आपको ऐसा लगता है की आपको ऐसा फूल
होता है की ये इंपॉर्टेंट नहीं होगा ये
इनफॉरमेशन हम छोड़ सकते हैं डोंट स्किप
आईटी इस बिलीव मी मुझे मुझे विश्वास करना
है की पुरी की पुरी इनफॉरमेशन सारे के
सारे इंपॉर्टेंट होती है भले आज वो
इंपॉर्टेंट ना लगे लेकिन उसे टाइम के बाद
आपको इंपॉर्टेंट लगेगी क्योंकि जितनी
ज्यादा आपके पास इनफॉरमेशन होगी उतना
ज्यादा हैकिंग सिनेरियो क्रिएट कर सकते हो
और उसे इनफॉरमेशन उसे करके आप अच्छे तरीके
से एक्सप्लोरर परफॉर्म कर सकते हो किसी भी
टारगेट के ऊपर ऑर्गेनाइजेशन के ऊपर
चलो अब मैं बात करता हूं देखो हम उसे करने
वाले मैं खुद से उसे करने वाला हूं रिचुअल
वर्क आर उसे करूंगा उसके अंदर अगर काली
निक उसे करते हो तो आईटी इस एन वेरी बटर
क्योंकि काली निक काफी अच्छा ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम और उसको काफी हद तक एनालाइज करेगा
क्योंकि मोबाइल फोन उसे करने से क्या हो
सकता है धोखे से आपने किसी भी एप्लीकेशन
को आप क्लिक कर दिया तो वहां से आपके
अनुमति सीधी अनप्रोटेक्टेड हो जाति है और
आप क्या कर सकते हो एक्सपोज हो जाओगे तो
आप बात करने वाले हैं हम सीखने वाले हैं
जो ट्रेडिशनल मैथ्स आपका नॉन टेक्निकल
मैथर्ड हैं हम वो परफॉर्म करने वाले हैं
ट्विटर ओपन 100 से इंटेलिजेंस के ऊपर तो
बिकॉज़ क्योंकि ज्यादा आर्टिकल हैकर्स और
हमें कोई भी टेस्ट मिस नहीं करना चाहिए
इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग के मामले पर हम कोई भी
स्टेप मिक्स करने का रिस्क नहीं ले सकते
तो
हम अभी परफॉर्म करने वाले हैं बिल्कुल
लाइव जान वाले हैं अपने टारगेट
परफॉर्म करने वाले हैं कौन सा मेथड उसे
करके ट्रेडिशनल मेथड नॉन टेक्निकल मेथड
उसे करने वाले हैं उसके बाद ही हम
टेक्निकल जाएंगे क्योंकि नॉन टेक्निकल
मेथड में के पाओ में जितनी ज्यादा
इनफॉरमेशन आप कलेक्ट कर पाओगे उतना ज्यादा
इजी हो जाएगा आपको टेक्निकल मेथड में
इनफॉरमेशन को दीप रेकों करने में तो चलो
फिर हम चलते हैं
और
स्टार्ट करते हैं
तो सबसे पहले आपको सबसे पहले आपको जो आपका
ट्विटर है
तो काफी अच्छी बात है अगर फेक अकाउंट तो
नहीं है तो आप क्या कर सकते हो आप अपने
अकाउंट से क्या कर सकते हो लॉगिन कीजिए
साइन इन कीजिए भाई इसका एक कम है देखो
विदाउट साइनिंग किया क्या कर सकते हो आप
इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग कर सकते हो लेकिन वहां
पर रिस्ट्रिक्शंस है उतनी ज्यादा
इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग नहीं कर पाओगे जितनी
ज्यादा इनफॉरमेशन है आप लोग इन करने के
बाद साइन इन करने के बाद कर पाओगे क्योंकि
साइन इन होने के बाद क्या है की आप उसे
डेटाबेस के अंदर हो क्योंकि आप उसे डाटा
केवल कर सकते हो लेकिन विदाउट साइनिंग
आपके कुछ डाटा बेस के ऊपर आप क्या रिजल्ट
ले सकते हो बट पुरी परफॉर्म नहीं कर सकते
जब बात करली परफॉर्म करने की आई है तो
आपको क्या करना पड़ेगा उसे सिस्टम के अंदर
जाना ही पड़ेगा तो आज का हमारा जो हम
टारगेट करने वाले हैं बेसिकली दिस इसे डी
एजुकेशन परपज ओनली तो आज हम जिसको टारगेट
करने वाले हैं पेटीएम कंपनी है उसको हम
टारगेट करने वाले हैं टोटली आपके सामने
करने वाला हूं तो अभी पर एग्जांपल आपको
दिखाई दे रहा होगा की मैंने साइन इन किया
हुआ है तो अब हम करते हैं देखो यह सर्च
बार आपको दिखाई दे रहा होगा
दिखाई दे रहा था की ससुराल में हम क्या
करेंगे अब पर एग्जांपल हमारे पास एक ऐसा
कीबोर्ड है हमारे पास कोई इनफॉरमेशन नहीं
है हमारे पास एक के शब्द है जिसको हम बोल
रहे हैं पेटीएम अब मैं पेटीएम को क्या
कहता हूं सर्च करता हूं उसके अंदर ए टी
अभी वैसे कुछ ये इसमें देखते हैं अभी
फोल्ड डॉ करके कुछ इनफॉरमेशन हमें मिल रही
है
अभी हम जैसे स्लो डॉ स्लो डॉ करें तो हमें
यहां पर
इनफॉरमेशन मिल रही है की पेटीएम पेटीएम
केयर पेटीएम करते हैं मैं एक बार व्यू जो
कर लेट हूं तो क्या-क्या इनफॉरमेशन
देखना कभी भी आप एक बार जब एक बार आप
कंफर्म हो जो की ये आपका पेटीएम का वेब
पेज जो है ये आपका पेटीएम का वेब पेज है
ये उसका प्रोफाइल पेज है तो आपको क्या
करना है एक बार चेक करें अभी तक मुझे
कंफर्म नहीं है बट क्या है की हम देख सकते
क्योंकि ये लोगो पेटीएम का लगा हुआ है और
काफी कुछ देखने को मिलता है हमें कम करते
हैं जैसे हम इस पे एक बार और करता हूं
यहां क्या इनफॉरमेशन
डेट नेवर फेल ओके तो इंडिया का
पेटीएम करो तो हमारे पास यहां पर क्या है
की अभी आपको देखो अगर एक और चीज आपको बता
देता हूं मैं
की अगर आप किसी भी ऑर्गेनाइजेशन को किसी
भी कंपनी को अगर टारगेट करने वाले हो तो
सबसे पहले एक कम करो आप उसका गूगल कीजिए
गूगल करने के बाद आप जाइए एक बार गूगल पे
जाइए और आपको क्या करना है एक बार अबाउट
पेटीएम कर देना अबाउट पेटीएम
कर देता हूं तो देखिए आपको देखने को
मिलेगा
सोशल मीडिया पर देखो
तो अभी देखिए यहां पर क्या इनफॉरमेशन है
क्योंकि देखो कोई भी वेबसाइट होती है उसके
अबाउट में काफी इनफॉरमेशन आपको देखने को
मिलती है अगर ज्यादा पॉपुलर कंपनी होगी तो
ये उन्होंने उसको वहां पर उसके कांटेक्ट
नंबर उसकी ईमेल ईमेल उसके सोशल मीडिया
हैंडलर्स पेज आपको मिल जाएंगे तो यही
इनफॉरमेशन हमें चाहिए होती है स्टार्टिंग
में क्योंकि कोई भी स्टेप आगे बढ़ाने के
लिए हमें एक बेसिक यूजर नाम मैं कुछ एक
ऐसी चीज चाहिए होती है जिसके बेसिस पे हम
क्या करें अपने आगे बाढ़ सकते हैं अब
देखिए यहां पर आपको देखने को मिलेगा अब
मैं इसका क्या अबाउट पे सही है अबाउट पेज
अबाउट पेज अबाउट है क्या ये
ओके अबाउट उसमें कुछ है क्या इनफॉरमेशन हम
देखते हैं
आपको देखने को मिल रहा होगा एक ट्विटर
हैंडलर हैंडल है इसको राइटिंग न्यू तब मैं
ओपन करता हूं इंस्टाग्राम और फेसबुक के
लिए ट्विटर के लिए बात कर रहा हूं ओके तो
अब देखो अब इससे भी मुझे कंफर्म हो जाएगा
की क्या मैं जो चीज हमें इनफॉरमेशन फाइंड
आउट कंफर्म करने ग रहे हैं क्या वो सही है
या गलत है देखिए अभी देखने हैं हमें ये
ओपन हो रहा है ओपन
ये बिल्कुल पेटीएम आते डी पेटीएम
पेटीएम की पेटीएम का ऑफिशल क्या है वेब
पेज मिल गया
इसके बाद इसके बाद अगर ये यहां पे
इनफॉरमेशन देखोगे पेटीएम आगे इंडियन
मल्टीफंक्शनल फाइनेंशियल टेक्नोलॉजी
विजय शेखावत शर्मा अंदर 197 कम्युनिकेशन
ओके अब इसका फाउंडर हमारे पास फाउंडर की
इनफॉरमेशन है अगर
एन से है
जिओ भी यही है विजय शेखर शर्मा ओके और
रिवेन्यू हमें को मतलब नहीं है ओके अब
इसका एरियाज और इंडिया जापान ओके अब हम
क्या करते हैं हमारे पास ये इनफॉरमेशन है
प्रोफाइल्स यहां पे देखने को मिल रही है
तो हम नोट मेकिंग करेंगे
नोट मेकिंग करने के लिए
की पहले तो पेटीएम का हैंडल है हमारे पास
अभी इधर जाता हूं मैं तो हमारे पास क्या
है की ये देखने को मिल रहा है ओके पेटीएम
@ पेटीएम
मैं कॉपी और
1 मिनट
सॉरी पर डिस्टरबेंस
देखो
वही कम करते हम विशेष को कॉपी करते हैं
नो नो नो नो डोंट क्लिक करें
और यह नोट डॉ कर लेते हैं
इतनी इनफॉरमेशन हमारे पास है इसके अलावा
भी कोई इनफॉरमेशन है क्या इसके अंदर
प्रोफाइल नो अभी हमारे पास इतनी इनफॉरमेशन
यहां से देखने को मिल रही है चलो इतनी
काफी एनालिसिस स्टार्ट करते हैं अभी
एनालिसिस कर रहे हैं तो हमारे पास और भी
कुछ देखने के लिए @ पेटीएम केयर काफी कुछ
है हमारे पास पेटीएम मनी तो हमें कम करते
हैं सभी को हम नोट डॉ करके देख लेते हैं
अदर हो सकता है
तो हम क्या देखेंगे
नेक्स्ट है पेटीएम मनी
पेटीएम
मनी
उसके बाद बात करते हैं पेटीएम पेटीएम
पेमेंट बैंक
@
एटीएम बैंक
के नाम
पर बिजनेस भी है काफी कुछ इनफॉरमेशन
भी देख लेते हैं
और बिजनेस बी यू
एस आई एन आई
टी
बिजनेस पेटीएम बिजनेस
क्रैक किया है इतना इनफॉरमेशन मैंने क्या
है इसके बड़े में पता किया है इतना मुझे
पता चल गया है अभी फादर है ऐसी हम इसी के
बेसिस पे स्टार्ट करने वाले हैं देखो अब
हमारे पास क्या है की अभी तक हम तो अभी
कुछ कर रहे हैं जो अभी जितना भी इनफॉरमेशन
को मैंने गदर किया है सारे के सारे
इंपॉर्टेंट ही है कोई भी ऐसे फालतू तो है
नहीं हम ये कम करते हैं देखिए अभी तो अभी
हमारे पास ये पीपल्स हैं क्योंकि हमारे
पास काफी है इनफॉरमेशन देखने को मिल रही
है
देखो क्या क्या निकाल के ए रहा है पेटीएम
से रिलेटेड
और ये साड़ी चीज अगर आप करो स्क्रॉल डॉ
करोगे काफी कुछ आपको देखने को मिलेगा
पेटीएम से रिलेटेड
[संगीत]
इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग परफॉर्म किया आपके
सामने आपको देखने को मिल रही होगी
अब देखना की आपको एक कम करना है पेटीएम से
लैपटॉप गया मैं टॉप से मुझे क्या करना है
मैंने फाइंड आउट किया नेक्स्ट नेक्स्ट
नेक्स्ट चलो ठीक है मुझे यहां पर देखा
मैंने लेटेस्ट से रिलेटेड देखो लेटेस्ट
में कुछ इनफॉरमेशन
थोड़ा सर्चिंग में टाइम लगेगा इसमें
और क्या देखने को मिल रहा है ओके लेटेस्ट
में क्या है इसमें कुछ देखने को मिल रहा
है ज्यादा पेटीएम कीबोर्ड इसमें सर्च किया
है
पीपल्स में हमें फाइंड आउट कर लिया तो
पीपल तो आपके सामने था अभी मैं क्या करता
हूं फोटोस में देखा हूं फोटोस
देखने को मिल रहा है
और काफी आपको स्लो डॉ करके देखना है देखिए
एक चीज ध्यान रखना
हर एक टाइप पर जाना क्यों जरूरी है चाहे
आप किसी इंडिविजुअल टारगेट के बड़े में
पता करने वाले हो चाहे आप किसी भी कंपनी
के टारगेट करने वाले हो या एवं कोई
कीवर्ड्स लेक जा रहे हो तब भी आपको क्या
करना है ये चीज ध्यान में रखना है की यहां
पर चांसेस क्या होते हैं की उन एम्पलाइज
की इनफॉरमेशन देखने को मिल जाए की या वो
कंपनी के कस्टमर हो कस्टमर से रिलेटेड
इनफॉरमेशन आपको यहां रेवल हो रही हो या
कोई मैनेजर्स रिलेटेड भी इनफॉरमेशन लीव
बिल हो रही वो साड़ी इनफॉरमेशन आपको देखने
को मिल शक्ति है जैसे की अभी हमें पीपल के
अंदर क्या देखने को मिला अभी इसके हैंडल्स
देखने को मिले ट्विटर हैंडल किसके ऑफिशल
पेटीएम के
अगर एक इसलिए मैं बोलना हूं की यहां पर
बहुत साड़ी डांस है की आपको कुछ
इंटरेस्टिंग इनफॉरमेशन देखने को मिले आपके
टारगेट कंपनी के बड़े में आपके टारगेट के
बड़े में अब एक बार सोचिए की अगर आप
सक्सेसफुली किसी भी एम्पलाई यार कस्टमर से
रिलेटेड अपने टारगेट कंपनी की इनफॉरमेशन
फाइंड आउट करने में सक्सेसफुल हो जाते हैं
तो काफी इंपॉर्टेंट इनफॉरमेशन आप लोगों के
लिए क्योंकि
बाद में क्या कर सकते हो जब भी आप क्या
करोगे आपकी आ पेंट है एक्सपर्टेशन के
स्टेप परफॉर्म करोगे तो एक्सप्लोइटेशन
स्टेप हम करने के लिए आपको बहुत सारे
हैकिंग सिनेरियस की जरूर होती है बहुत
सारे हैं हैकिंग सीनरियों और एक्टिंग
अटैकिंग उसका उसे करते हो और जब ये हैकिंग
सिनेरियो और अटैकिंग सिनेरियस को आप जब
उसे करोगे एक्सप्लोइटेशन करते वक्त तो
आपको वहां पर बहुत ज्यादा इनफॉरमेशन की
जरूर होती है हो सकता है की आपके पास जो
इनफॉरमेशन अवेलेबल है उसके बेसिस पे आप
एक्सप्लोरर ना कर पाव तो फरदर एक्सप्लोरर
करने के लिए आपको क्या करना पड़ेगा इन
इंडिविजुअल जो भी इनफॉरमेशन आपको कस्टमर
के इनफॉरमेशन मिली है या एंपलॉयर की
इनफॉरमेशन या मैनेजर की सीईओ की सीटों की
किसी भी इनफॉरमेशन देखने को मिली है उसको
क्या करना पड़ेगा आपको उसको इंडिविजुअल
टारगेट करना पड़ेगा इंडिविजुअल उसपे बट
परफॉर्म अटैक
करके रखती पड़ेगी
हर एक इनफॉरमेशन जो भी आप क्या करने वाले
परफॉर्म करने वाले हो गदर करने वाले ओपन
सोशल में काफी इंपॉर्टेंट इनफॉरमेशन होती
है इसी रीजन से मैं बोलना हूं की हर एक
चीज को आपको क्या करना है नोट डॉ करके
रखना है ताकि फ्यूचर में जब भी आपके
हैकिंग स्टेप आपको परफॉर्म करने की जरूर
पड़े कोई भी हैकिंग है जो परफॉर्म करने की
जरूर है उसे इनफॉरमेशन को उसे किया जा सके
उसके बेसिस पे काफी कुछ इनफॉरमेशन होगी
उसके बेसिक
को परफॉर्म कर पाओगे
अब बात करते हैं नेक्स्ट बढ़ते हैं अभी
देखो अभी तक मेरे पास इनफॉरमेशन ए गया अब
मैं क्या करता हूं की मेरे पास क्या है
पेटीएम का ऑफिशल पेज हैंडल हैंडल मिल गया
है मेरे को अब मैं क्या करता हूं आगे और
डी रेट लगा देता हूं अब मैं
@ लगा दिया मैं क्या करता हूं अभी तक
क्योंकि मेरे पास जितने भी इनफॉरमेशन ए
रही थी ओनली पेटीएम
ए रही थी ना की अदर दें पेटीएम
सबको पता है की यूजरनेम क्या होता है की
यूनिक नाम होता है हर एक प्रोफाइल के लिए
हर एक अकाउंट के लिए अब जितनी भी
इनफॉरमेशन यहां पे आपको देखने को मिलेगी
पोस्ट के अंदर जहां भी देख रहे हैं जो भी
इनफॉरमेशन आपको देखने को मिलेगी वो साड़ी
की साड़ी कौन सी इनफॉरमेशन होगी साड़ी की
साड़ी इनफॉरमेशन ओनली इसी
@ पेटीएम
करते हैं इसके बड़े में कुछ इनफॉरमेशन
फाइंड आउट करने की कोशिश करते हैं कुछ
यहां पे इंटरेस्टिंग मिलता है या नहीं है
पोस्ट के अंदर लेटेस्ट के अंदर कुछ
भी
प्रोसेस है
[संगीत]
ओके इसमें केंद्र को देखने को मिल रहा है
आपको क्रिकेट क्रिकेट
के बाद उसके बाद क्या किया अगर यहां पर
साइड में आपको कोई फोटो देखने को मिलेगा
आपको क्या करना है पहले फोटोस के अंदर
जाकर देख सकते हो की फोटोस पे अगर मैं
प्ले करके देखोगे कोई इनफॉरमेशन दे विली
हो रही है जैसे की ये रहा
है
पेटीएम
बिजनेस सेटलमेंट अमाउंट
जब भी आप किसी भी इमेज के ऊपर जब क्लिक
करने वाले हो तो यहां पर देखने को मिल रहा
है कमेंट्स रिप्लाई कमेंट्स पर एग्जाम
यहां पर आपको क्या करना है रीट्विट्स
देखने को मिल रही है और यहां पर आपको
देखने को मिल रहा होगा लाइक्स देखो आपको
हर एक को क्या करना है ओपन करके देखना है
कमेंट्स में आपको क्या देखने को मिल रहा
है रेट बिट्स में देखने को क्या मिल रहा
है लाइक्स में देखने का क्या मिल रहा है
पर एग्जांपल मैंने रिट्स को ओपन किया अभी
रिव्यू किया है ओके रेट
देखिए रेट वेट मैं आपको साइड में क्या
पढ़ने को मिलेगा की यहां पर क्या लिखा हुआ
रेट वेट के अंदर ये देखो
यहां पर किसी ने कुछ तो रिप्लाई किया हो
किसी ने किया है वैलिडिटी प्रमोशन है
देखो पेटीएम केयर डायरेक्ट पेटीएम पेटीएम
केयर ने इसको क्या किया है रिप्लाई किया
इसके अंदर
तो और भी कुछ इनफॉरमेशन आपको देखने को मिल
शक्ति है यहां पे तो एक चीज ध्यान रखना है
जब भी आप इस टाइप से इनफॉरमेशन
आपको देखने को मिल शक्ति है पर एग्जांपल
यहां पर क्या इनफॉरमेशन देख सकते हैं
देखने को मिल शक्ति है एम्पलाइज की
इनफॉरमेशन देखने को मिल शक्ति है अलग-अलग
डिफरेंस में के डिपार्मेंट के जो
एंपलॉयर्स हैं
उनकी इनफॉरमेशन देखने को मिल शक्ति है जो
कंपनी के अंदर कम कर देंगे हो सकता है की
टेक्निकल डिपार्मेंट है उसको समझदार है
उसको अवेयरनेस है बट ऐसे भी हो सकते हैं
जो नॉनटीक डिपार्मेंट होते हैं कर
डिपार्मेंट वो क्या उनके यहां पे
इनफॉरमेशन मिल सकते हैं जो उसे कंपनी के
अंदर कम कर रहे होंगे तो
अब ओनली यही चीज नहीं है बाकी ये भी आपको
देखने को मिल सकता है की आप किस चीज के
ऊपर बात कर रहे हैं कुछ ऐसी कोई इनफॉरमेशन
है कुछ ऐसी कोई चीज है कोई ऐसा
चल रहा है जिसके ऊपर वो बात कर रहे हैं
अगर वह बात करें डेफिनेटली क्या है की कोई
ना कोई कंपनी से ही बात कर रहा होगा तो
उससे भी हम क्या कर सकते हैं इनफॉरमेशन
कहते हैं कर सकते हैं एम्पलाई की हर किसी
की इनफॉरमेशन गदर कर सकते हैं जस्ट
एनालिसिस करके तो मैं एक चीज बोलूंगा आप
लोगों को डोंट लीव एनीथिंग ऑन डी ट्विटर
पेज ट्विटर पेज के ऊपर आपको कुछ भी नहीं
छोड़ना है आपको हर एक लाइक तो देखना है
एवं आपको टाइम क्योंकि आपको टाइम देना ही
पड़ेगा एनालाइज करना पड़ेगा हर चीज को
एनालाइज करके आपको क्या करना पड़ेगा
ज्यादा से ज्यादा इनफॉरमेशन कहते नहीं
करनी पड़ेगी क्योंकि हो सकता है की आपको
जल्दी ऐसा करोगे आपको टाइम लगेगा आपको
घंटा की बात नहीं दोनों की टाइम दिनों
लगेंगे
तो ऐसे में क्या होगा की आप जब इतना टाइम
लगेगा कुछ ऐसे सेंसेटिव इनफॉरमेशन देखने
को मिलेगी काफी
हेल्पफुल होगी आप आप लोगों के लिए तो अब
बात करते चलो आगे बढ़ते हैं इसमें और भी
देखते हैं कुछ हमें हमारे हाथ ग रहा है
पीपल के अंदर जाते हैं लोगों क्या इसको
देखने को मिल रहा है
पेटीएम साइबर सेल पेटीएम बैंक
एटीएम
मिल रहा है
[संगीत]
देखो एक और इनफॉरमेशन
@ पेटीएम
हो सकता है की उसके अंदर डिजाइंस ओके
नमस्ते नमस्ते
पर एजुकेशन परपज उसे करता हूं दो क्लेम ऑन
मी आई बिल ये क्या बोला देखो आई बिल स्टॉप
फाउंडर आते डी रेट पेटीएम मिस्टर और सी पी
ओ पे टी एम चलो देखो इनफॉरमेशन हमें देखने
को मिल रही है देखो तो अब मैं सभी को देखो
हर एक प्रोफाइल को अगर ध्यान से पढ़ोगे हर
एक चीज तो देखो तो कुछ ना कुछ आपको देखने
को मिल रहा है ये को क्या है अभी दिखे रही
है यहां पर देखो
अभी आपके सामने ही देखने को मिल रही है
यह तो थी की आप कंपनी का जो पेटीएम कंपनी
है उसका जो ऑफिशल वेब पेज विजिट करके तो
वेब पेज इसके ऊपर ट्विटर के ऊपर विजिट
करके कितनी इनफॉरमेशन गदर कर सकते हैं तो
जस्ट एक फ्रिक्शन ऑफ मिनट के अंदर जस्ट ए
वन परसेंट ऑफ इनफॉरमेशन भी नहीं था 1% ऑफ
इनफॉरमेशन में जब हम इतनी इनफॉरमेशन रेगर
कर पता था सोचो की हम कितना बड़ा सिनेरियो
हम क्रिएट कर सकते हैं इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग
के बेसिस पे तो अभी हमारे पास क्या है की
इतनी इनफॉरमेशन है तो हम क्या करते हैं
देखो एक और चीज बता देता हूं आपको की
अब जो भी अब यहां पर क्या है की पर
एग्जांपल यहां पर अभी इसकी इनफॉरमेशन तो
कुछ खास है नहीं यहां पर
क्या कंपनी पेटीएम की बैग चलते हैं हम
इसके बाद पेज पे
अब फॉलोइंग
बेसिकली
बट क्या है की जो भी फॉलोइंग और फॉलोअर्स
की इनफॉरमेशन क्या देखो जो फॉलोइंग होती
है ना वो काफी कुछ इनफॉरमेशन डेविल कर
देती है किसी भी कंपनी के कंपनी के
फॉलोइंग जो होती है क्योंकि कंपनी किसी को
अगर फॉलो कर रही है इसका मतलब क्या है की
वो काफी इंपॉर्टेंट सकता है कंपनी के लिए
तभी वो उसको फॉलो कर रही होती है तो वहां
पे उसका हो सकता है की उसके फ्रेंड्स हो
एवं उसका पार्टनर वो भी आपको इनफॉरमेशन
देखने को मिल शक्ति है तो अब ये चीज होगी
अब बात करते हैं देखो अभी तक कंपनी के वेब
पेज को ही विजिट किया हमने वहां से काफी
कुछ इनफॉरमेशन हमने निकाल है अब बात
करेंगे हम की जो इंडिविजुअल परसंस हैं जो
इंडिविजुअल्स परसंस है अभी तक हमें किसी
को भी इंडिविजुअल को टारगेट नहीं किया अब
क्या इंडिविजुअल्स परसंस को हम क्या
करेंगे टारगेट करेंगे
कोशिश करते हैं उसके बड़े में इनफॉरमेशन
कुछ करें टारगेट कंपनी के बड़े में अभी तक
हमने क्या है जस्ट ओनली कंपनी का वेब पेज
विजिट किया है पहले मैं क्या करूं नोट्स
मेकिंग कर लेट हूं मैं अपनी देखो
मुझे इसकी हम क्या करते हैं
इसकी हमारे पास क्या पेटीएम आईडी है
पेटीएम आईडी है
आ विजय शेखर यह इसकी क्या है पेटीएम
है
@ पेटीएम वाइव्स को हाईलाइट बट क्या की
यहां पे कुछ हमें देखने को मिल रहा है
देखो इसके अंदर और भी अब ऊपर से क्या है
देखो इन्होंने अपने क्या है यहां पे
लोकेशन भी मेंशन की हुई है ऊपर से क्या है
की इंडिया इंडिया के ऊपर से कब जॉइन किया
था उन्होंने नवंबर 2008 में ये भी
इनफॉरमेशन मिलने की देखने को मिल रही है
यहां पर अभी जस्ट इनफॉरमेशन
देखने को मिल रही है चलो इसको न्यू टाइप
में ओपन करते हैं
ओके सीईओ है पेटीएम मनी ओके
और क्या है मुंबई इंडिया ये मुंबई में
रहते हैं 2013 में जॉइन किया है चलो अब
इनके बड़े में काफी इनफॉरमेशन मिलेगी चलो
हम बात करते हैं
तो पेटीएम मनी है हमारे पास
ये है चलो
पेटीएम मनी कभी हमारे पास सीईओ मिल गए तो
क्या है
ट्विटर हैंडल क्या है इनका
@
लोकेशन शेर की हुई है ओके और यह क्या है
इंटर करते हैं तो सीपीयू की इनफॉरमेशन
हमारे पास में देखने को मिल रही है
ओके ये भी इनफॉरमेशन मिल गई नेक्स्ट अबाउट
पेटीएम
सिस्टम
आर्किटेक्चर
अब हम सबसे पहले टारगेट करेंगे
पॉपुलर इंसान है तो
दो टारगेट
बात करते हैं इनके बड़े में इनफॉरमेशन
देखने को मिल रहे हो काफी फोटोस देखने को
मिल रही है तो हरे को क्या करना आपको ओपन
करना है और देखना है पर एग्जांपल मैं क्या
कहूं पर एग्जांपल इसी फोटो देखा हूं देखिए
इस फोटो को मैं देखा हूं और ये क्या कर
रहे हैं इधर अब इसके ऊपर क्या है आपको
देखोगे अगर ए
अब क्या इन्होंने अपने कुछ फोटो डालो यहां
पर क्या है कमेंट सिक्स हैं
ओके 1 मिनट
की इनफॉरमेशन रेट विथ ओके ओके ओके आई बिल
नोट तो अब यहां पर कुछ इनफॉरमेशन देखने को
मिल रही है देखो
ओके नेक्स्ट
और
योर अटेंशन इन मी कैसे वेयर मी मनी गॉड
स्ट्रैंथ और नोट ए सिंगल रहने
मुझे कुछ इंटरेस्टिंग यही लगा की कुछ हो
सकता है
अभी से ठीक है अब तब तक हम लोग क्या करते
हैं अभी उसके बाद क्या करना है देखो एक
चीज नोटिस करनी है की जब भी आप रेट और
लाइक्स की बात करते हैं तो एक चीज देखिए
एक चीज हमें सोचिए कभी भी की आप लोगों ने
एक चीज नोटिस की होगी की
क्या कोई किसी को ऐसे ही लाइक या ट्वीट कर
देता है बिना किसी रीजन के कोई किसी को
ऐसे लाइक और ट्वीट तो करता नहीं हुआ ना
बिना किसी रीजन के तो एक चीज छोटी है की
वह कोई भी हो सकता है या तो कोई कस्टमर हो
सकता है या कोई पार्टनर भी हो सकता है कोई
फ्रेंड भी हो सकता है यह इनफॉरमेशन हो
शक्ति है तो इसलिए मैं बोलना हूं की जब भी
खासकर की जब आप नॉन टेक्निकल मेथड के थ्रू
आप क्या कर रहे हो ओपन सोशल रिलिजियस
परफॉर्म कर रहे हो तो काफी इंपॉर्टेंट
होती है
साड़ी की साड़ी चीज क्या
इंपॉर्टेंट होती है
नो डाउट करना है अभी इस टाइप की इनफॉरमेशन
मुझे यहां से हो शक्ति है इन फोटो के इन
रिटायरमेंट से किस टाइप की इनफॉरमेशन मिल
शक्ति है एवं अगर मैं बैक करता हूं की एवं
मैं बैक करता हूं की पर एग्जांपल अब ये
खुद से सीईओ है या देखो मैं पुरी एग्जांपल
यहां पर इनके फॉलो फॉलो विंग है ये ₹856
लोगों को फॉलो करते हैं देखो 856 लोगों के
फॉलो करते हैं ये फॉलो फॉलोज हैं तो किस
टाइप की इनफॉरमेशन यहां पर मिल शक्ति है
हो सकता है की आपको यहां इनफॉरमेशन मिले
कोट
ऑफ दिस कंपनी एवं या को सीटू और कोई दूसरी
कंपनी के भी इनके साथ क्या है पार्टनर्स
हो इनके साथ इनके बंटी हो उनको भी फॉलो
करते मिल सकते हैं
उनकी कंपनी के अंदर उनकी भी इनफॉरमेशन है
आपको देखने को मिल सकते हैं या कुछ नॉर्मल
एम्पलाइज होते हैं या कस्टमर होते हैं
उनकी इनफॉरमेशन भी आपको यहां पर देखने को
नॉर्मल इंफाल कस्टमर की इनफॉरमेशन यहां
देखने को मिलेंगे लेकिन क्या फॉलोइंग में
फॉलोअर्स में देखने को मिल सकते क्योंकि
वो फॉलो कर रहे होंगे क्योंकि इनकी कंपनी
है क्योंकि इसमें कम करते हैं तो और एक और
चीज है इसके बेसिस पे की अगर की हम यहां
पर और भी चांसेस है की हायर प्रोफाइल अगर
आपको यहां देखने को मिल शक्ति है तो हो
सकता है की कोई भी हायर प्रोफाइल मिलती है
सी ओ सी टी और अगर कंपनी तो हो सकता है की
वो क्लोज फ्रेंड हो एक दूसरे के साथ तो इस
तरीके से आपको क्या करना होगा जब भी आप
ऊपर सो सेंड करें
तो ऊपर से देखो यहां पे देखने को मिल रहा
है टॉपिक यहां पर देखो
एमडीसीओ@ यह इसको क्या है फॉलो करते हैं
मतलब राधिका गुप्ता कुछ तो है तो मतलब और
भी अगर सी हो उसकी इनफॉरमेशन यहां पर
देखने को मिलती है तो मोस्ट रनिंग
साइकिलिंग स्विमिंग परसों
तो यहां पर क्या ये हो सकता है की वह उनके
क्लोज फ्रेंड हो तो आपको क्या करना होगा
जब भी आप क्या कर सकते हो अगर आप एक बेस्ट
ओपन शॉट इंटेलिजेंस परफॉर्म करना चाहते हो
अगर आप बेस्ट ऑफर्स उसे इंटेलिजेंस
परफॉर्मर बन्ना चाहते हो तो आपको क्या
करना होगा सबसे पहले आपको की टूल्स के साथ
साथ आपको आम सेंस का उसे करना ही होगा
एनालिसिस आपको करना ही होगा और एनालिसिस
के बेसिस पे आपको सबसे बड़ी कैपेबिलिटी
कैपेबिलिटी आपकी क्या हनी चाहिए ना सबसे
बड़ी कैपेबिलिटी आपकी हनी चाहिए की आप
चीजों को एक दूसरे के साथ कोड लेट कैसे कर
पाते हो उन चीजों के साथ लिंक कैसे बना
सकता हो उन चीजों को एक दूसरे के साथ कैसे
जोड़ पाते हो तो यहां पर क्या है देखो
आपका कम है की इन चीजों को आपस में जोड़ना
कैसे है कैसे रिलेट करना है क्योंकि
जैसे-जैसे आप चाट पढ़ोगे जैसे ट्वीट्स
पढ़ोगे लाइक्स पढ़ोगे कमेंट पढ़ोगे फोटो
पर ट्वीट पढ़ोगे हर एक चीज को पढ़ो देखो
काफी देखो ये काफी बड़ी कंपनी है और इतनी
ज्यादा बड़ी नहीं है लेकिन काफी बड़ी है
लेकिन इसके चीजों को इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग
करना काफी डिटेल रिसर्च करना आईटी बिल टेक
टाइम नोट फॉरवर्ड एवं टेक योर फूल मठ
क्योंकि साड़ी चीजों लेकिन जब अगर आपने
टाइम दिया है अगर आप इसको क्या कर रहे हो
टाइम दे रहे हो तो डेफिनेटली आप क्या
करोगे सब एक टाइम के बाद इसकी साड़ी
इनफॉरमेशन को एनालिसिस करोगे लिंक कर लोग
तो उसके बाद आपको क्या है की एक ऐसा
सिनेरियो इतनी ज्यादा इनफॉरमेशन आपको
मिलेगी इतनी चारी को इतनी जल्दी ज्यादा
चीज आपके पास कलेक्ट करती मिलेगी कितनी
चीज इतना अटैकिंग सिनेरियो होगा ना तो
आपका हैकिंग का जो अटैकिंग करियो इतना
बड़ा बन जाएगा की आपके पास आपको उसके पास
अटैक कम पद जाएंगे आप सोचते रहोगे की किस
पे क्या परफॉर्म करना है मतलब आप इतना
बड़ा अटैक नहीं रही हो परफॉर्म कर सकते हो
बना सकते हो विद डी हेल्प ऑफ ओपन सोर्स
इंटेलिजेंस ऑन लीव
करना आपका कम है मैं सब आपको गाइड करूंगा
तो मैं सब इस तरीके से अब फॉलोअर्स फॉलो
नहीं है फॉलोअर्स में ये इनफॉरमेशन आपको
देखने को मिल शक्ति है ये अटैक नारिया
बनाना ये चीज लिंक इनफॉरमेशन को एक दूसरे
साथ लिंक करना वो करना है ये क्या कम है
जब आप सच में किसी एक टारगेट को अटैक करने
वाले हो सच में किसी एक टारगेट के बड़े
में आप क्या करने वाले हो इनफॉरमेशन
गैदरिंग करने वाले हो तो उसे कैसे में
आपको ये साड़ी चीज खुद से ही करनी पड़ेगी
क्योंकि अभी मैं करने हूं अभी जस्ट नॉन
टेक्निकल कुछ एक या दो बोलेंगे 4% भी हम
ले लिए और हमारे क्या की 1 घंटा हो गया तो
इस तरीके से आपको ये साड़ी चीज खुद से ही
परफॉर्म करने पड़ेगी और ये साड़ी चीज वो
आपको क्या करना पड़ेगा राइट डॉ करके रखना
होगा आपकी नोटबुक के अंदर आपकी बुक्स के
अंदर अभी देखो हम यहां से मैं ओपन करता
हूं की ट्वीट रिलेटेड और अब इनफॉरमेशन
अभी इसको क्या है अगर मैं ओपन करता हूं
युटुब के अंदर तो देखिए अगर मैं इसके अंदर
इसको ओपन करता हूं न्यू टैब के अंदर तो
देखें इसके बड़े में कुछ इनफॉरमेशन आपको
देखने का डेफिनेटली मिलेगी
ऐसे नहीं है की एक मिनट में एक दिन में हो
जाएगी नोट पॉसिबल
टीपू देखिए अब यह पेटीएम की सीपीयू पेटीएम
इनसाइड और को पेटीएम ओके यह देखते हैं
देखो चलो अब इनका अगर हम क्या करते हैं
फॉलोइंग देखते हैं किसको फॉलो करें
वो
और एक मिनट क्या करते हैं इनकी पोलर पीपल
फॉलोज में इनके उसमें है क्या
तृतीय अग्रवाल ओके ओके
वो भी काफी बड़ी लिस्ट है हो सकता है की
फॉलो करते हुए नहीं भी करते हो आई डोंट नो
की नो यहां पर मुझे कुछ दिखानी है ओके तो
फॉलो यह नहीं करते उनको बट
सीईओ ऑफ
पेटीएम ओके तो नेक्स्ट नेक्स्ट तो हमें
क्या करना पड़ेगा
फोटोस में देखने को मिलेगी अगर मैं बात
करता हूं मीडिया की
ओके फिर रिप्लाई इन्होंने कितनो को
रिप्लाई किया चलो
बिल्डिंग
4 घंटे पहले 3 घंटे पहले
हम क्या कर सकते हैं
अप अमाउंट हो गया क्या
इस तरीके से हमें क्या करना पड़ेगा इनको
ढूंढना पड़ेगा बिल्डिंग
करते हैं देखो
तो इस तरीके से क्या है की देखो अभी आपको
क्या करना पड़ेगा मल्टीप्लेक्स प्रोफाइल्स
को देखना होगा और एक दूसरे से क्रॉस चेक
करने की कोशिश करनी होगी तो यहां पर क्या
है की काफी इनफॉरमेशन आपको देखने को मिल
शक्ति है काफी इनफॉरमेशन देखने को मिल
शक्ति है इनफॉरमेशन देखने को मिल शक्ति है
लाइक डेट की ये आपको देखो एक चीज नोटिस
करो हम जिसको टारगेट कर रहे हैं जिसको भी
हम यहां टारगेट करने की कोशिश करें वो
काफी काफी पॉपुलर पोजीशन परसों है मतलब
पॉपुलर
डेजिग्नेशन पर है
बात आई है तो एक वीकनेस होती है हर किसी
के अंदर सिक्योरिटी अवेयरनेस रिलेटेड है
तो अब कई बार अनजाने में कुछ ऐसी ट्वीट्स
कर दी जाति हैं
या हो सकता है कुछ ऐसी इनफॉरमेशन जो उसको
नहीं करनी चाहिए थी क्योंकि
इतना परफॉर्म कर लो लेकिन कहानी ना कहानी
सिक्योरिटी अवेयरनेस र ही जाति है और धोखे
से कुछ ऐसी ट्वीट कर दी जाए जिसकी वजह
से निकालना हो उठाना पद सकता है तो इसलिए
मैं आपको बोलना हूं की कुछ भी मत छोड़िए
प्रोफाइल को चेक करते हुए
[संगीत]
ठीक है डोंट लीव कुछ भी नहीं छोड़ना है आप
लोगों को हर चीज आपको क्या करनी है चेक
करनी ही करनी ही है ओके तो ये आपको पता चल
गया होगा तो ये था देखो की आपका ट्रेडिशनल
मेथड ट्रेडिशनल मेथड से आपको चीजों को लेट
कैसे करना है टेक्निकल
किड इनफॉरमेशन कल भी आपकी क्लास होगी कल
भी आपकी लाइव क्लास होगी से टाइम होगी से
ड्यूरेशन होगी कल भी आपकी क्लास होगी
क्योंकि कल हम टेक्निकल्स पढ़ने वाले हैं
बट क्या है की देखा हूं की कितने लोग क्या
इनफॉरमेशन और लेट कर पाते हैं तो अगेन मैं
बोल देता हूं की जो थिंग्स आर डी जस्ट पर
एजुकेशन परपज ओनली
हमारा किसी को भी किसी प्रकार की हनी
पहुंचाना नहीं
एम्पलाई को हर एक को या एवं सीईओ को किसी
एम्पलाई की इनफॉरमेशन पता करना उसकी बेसिस
पे हो करना सबको क्या मिल जाएगी बट क्या
आएगी
टाइम कंजूमिंग प्रोसेस आपको टाइम देना
होगा जब आप ओपन सोर्सेस इंटेलिजेंस के
फील्ड में आओगे आपको क्या करना पड़ेगा
टाइम तो देना ही पड़ेगा अगर आपने अच्छा
खास टाइम दे दिया अपने फर्स्ट स्टेप्स पे
तो नेक्स्ट आपके जो हैकिंग सिनेरियस होते
हैं उनको काफी अच्छे से आप इंप्लीमेंट कर
पाओगे क्योंकि आपके पास अच्छा खास स्पेस
होगा की आप किसको कब क्या टारगेट करना है
किसको कैसे करना है किस क्या इनफॉरमेशन
गैलरी इनकी एक दूसरे से अगर आप लिंक करें
एक दूसरे से जोड़ पे तो काफी अच्छी
इनफॉरमेशन काफी अच्छी इनफॉरमेशन आपको
देखने को मिल शक्ति है तो प्लीज मुझे ये
बताइए आज की क्लास में मजा आया नहीं आया
और नेक्स्ट क्लास में और भी ज्यादा मजा
आने वाला काफी इंटरेस्टिंग
फिल्म तो नहीं कर रहे हो बाकी लोग
किसी को बता दीजिए पहले मुझे
फटाफट कर लेंगे
अगर जल्दी करना खत्म कर देंगे
हम आपको सर्च करके भी देगा वो चीजों को
कैसे देखा जाता है
स्टार्टिंग अच्छी है बाकी क्या हुआ बीच
में
चलो
पांच मिनट आप लोगों का क्या डाउट सेशन है
5 मिनट में आप लोगों को कुछ भी डाउट्स हैं
तो आप हमसे पूछ सकते हैं उसके बाद हम सेशन
को एड कर देंगे
रितेश कुमार कम करता हूं अभी
देखिए खुश क्या होता है
[संगीत]
की जो ओपन इनफॉरमेशन होती है एक बात बताइए
एक चीज ध्यान रखना कभी भी
आज के टाइम में आपको लगता है की कंपनी के
लिए सबसे ज्यादा क्या है की बिजनेस जरूरी
है बिजनेस में पैसा बनाना जरूरी है उसके
लिए अगर थोड़ा बहुत सिक्योरिटी के साथ
कंप्रोमाइज करना पड़े तो वो कर लेती है
क्या कर लेते हो कॉम्पोनेंट्स कर लेती है
आप एक भी एक चीज बताइए आपके ट्विटर सोशल
मीडिया प्लेटफॉर्म ऐसे हैं यहां पर क्या
अवेयर हो कुछ चीज ऐसी होती कहानी ना कहानी
धोखे से कुछ भी कहानी भी आप ट्वीट कर पाते
हो एवं हो सकता है की जो स्टूडेंट को खुद
हैंडल ना करते हो और कोई उनका और हैंडलर
हो उसको सिक्योरिटी अवेयरनेस ना हो तो
सिक्योरिटी अवेयरनेस कितनी भी रख डन बट
क्या है गलतियां हो बगैर होती नहीं रहती
नहीं है और कोई भी एक गलती क्या है की
किसी को भी एक्सपोज करो अगर जब तक गलतियां
नहीं होगी तो साइबर सिक्योरिटी फील्ड ही
रहेगा तो गलतियां हैं तो हम अगर गलती यह
नहीं है तो हम नहीं हैं और गलतियां तो हनी
ही है क्योंकि वूमेन बीइंग है उसे गलतियां
हनी ही है
टेक्निकल हम कल पढ़ेंगे ना सर हां बिल्कुल
कल टेक्निकल पढ़ेंगे और कल से टाइम क्लास
होगी कल भी डेफिनेटली क्लास होगी
और करते हैं और अगर लास्ट में आपको यही
बोलना चाहता हूं की अगर आप लोगों को हमारे
सेशन अच्छा लगा और लाइक और सब्सक्राइब
करना ना भोले और हमें लिंक पेज पर जाकर
प्लीज कमेंट कीजिए और यहां पे भी कमेंट कर
दीजिए
और बाकी लोगों को भी काफी कुछ सीखने को
मिलता है
तो अगर आप लोगों को ऐसा लगता है की अच्छा
नहीं है तो डिसलाइक भी कर दीजिए नो
प्रॉब्लम अगर आपको लगता है कुछ और कुछ कम
का नहीं लगा आप लोगों के तो आप कमेंट आउट
कर सकते हो हमें कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है हम
उसके उसके ऊपर अपना 100% देंगे और हम
इंप्रूव करने की कोशिश करेंगे तो आज का
सेशन एंड करते हैं बाय बाय